c'est une manifestation qui a permis de
mettre en avant la culture de la
martinique mais à travers deux axes qui
était l'art et la musique donc ce qu'on
a fait c'est qu'on voulait associer
l'art d'une partie visuelle avec des
photographes des lives artistes et la
partie musique avec un musicien de chez
nous que vous prenez tout ce qui était
exigé d'un gars et on voulait associer
ces axes ensemble pour créer vraiment
une interaction est un échange avec les
artistes à la fois et le public et ça a
été un franc succès parce que on a pu
toucher la communauté de chez nous qui
vit à londres mais aussi on a pu toucher
des anglais qui ne connaissait pas du
tout deux concepts ça a traversé de
l'angleterre à paris de paris aux
antilles
j'ai des amis des etats-unis qui m'ont
appelé pour me dire mais comment ça se
fait et c'était vraiment une chose qui
nous tenait à coeur à moi et à lorraine
parce que moi j'ai vécu sept ans à lons
de lorraine il vit toujours et avec huit
ans et on voulait vraiment on a constaté
quelque chose c'est que à londres on
connaît la martinique mais on ne connaît
pas notre culture et de ce fait on s'est
dit pourquoi ne pas combiner nos
passions donc la passion de lorraine
caylar et moi c'est la musique que j'ai
une agence d'événementiel qui est basé à
londres et je me suis dit c'est vraiment
une chose qui nous tient à coeur et donc
on va le faire et c'est on l'a fait on a
fait on s'était c'était vraiment un long
processus
on a eu des bons on a eu des petits
couacs on a eu vraiment des challenge
qu'on a relevé pour finalement avoir une
soirée qui était magnifique un échange
avec le public
vraiment des gens qui ont découvert la
martinique la culture des photographes
des vues de la martinique
et puis la musique avec easy
diacre et un refrain avec avec cette
audience en leur posant des questions
qui étaient comment vous vous rappelez
de la martinique quand vous êtes au loin
donc les gens ont pu donner dès lors
leurs idées ils ont pu échanger et de là
il a pu créer un refrain avec eux qui a
été enregistré en live
donc je suis très très content de cette
première édition et on travaille déjà
sur la seconde édition